un soleil de plomb de fortes chaleurs
malgré la rentrée il flotte comme un air
de vacances partout où l'on se promène
au marché de versailles les habitants
affluaient à nouveau entre les étals de
quoi ravir les marchands c'est bien
d'avoir la peau temps
nous on voit beau temps c'est le
week-end
et pourtant le samedi et le dimanche
portage en écharpe et pourtant il semble
que le travail ne soit pas la priorité
de tous jogging vélo ou encore badminton
entre collègues c'est avec plus de 30
degrés que ces sportifs rattrapant
n'étaient plus que maussade de 30
septembre est de retrouver le beau temps
comme ça ça fait vraiment plaisir puis
c'est un moment convivial parce qu'on
est tous ensemble ici on profite du du
parc du soleil peut déjà ging à des
câbles et puis ça remonte le moral je
suis à toi ce moment qu'est ce qu'il
faut c'est super sympa parce que ça
donne du baume au coeur ça permet aux
gens de retourner
dans un espace de travail b avec eux
soleil la chaleur et les la beauté des
paysages et en même temps je fais très
très chaud on ne sait pas c'est pas
évident pour tellement des températures
supérieures aux normales de saison de
cet avis degré un bain de soleil qui
fait du bien aux travailleurs et aux
étudiants ça fait du bien on peut
prendre des verts en terrasse enfin en
profite voilà après ce mauvais temps
d'été mais qui arrive peut-être un peu
trop tard tous les gens travaillent
maintenant une reprise on n'a pas
profité des vacances on n'a pas eu le
temps et du coup forcément les vacances
on va on crache pas dans la soupe ça
fait du bien ces chaises vides attendent
donc preneur avant le retour du mauvais
temps qui devrait à nouveau pointé le
bout de son nez en fin de semaine